Sports Illustrated senior basketball
writer joining us a Mannix how are you
what Papa to Dan
alright you want to answer the poll
question the glove and give it to Mannix
okay if you had to lose one who would
you want to keep if you're the Warriors
Kevin Durant or draymond Green oh I
don't think there's any question it's
Kevin Durant you know III think there's
going I wrote a little bit about this
today you know there's gonna be some
questions internally in Golden State
about how much you pay draymond Green in
2020 I mean he's going to be looking for
that max level payday but I believe he's
going to be 30 when when that contract
comes up and he doesn't have the type of
game that I think will age and other
people think really will age
particularly well I mean he's a bit
undersized for his position and he
doesn't have a strong perimeter game so
you throw those two things in and do you
really want to give a player like that
as great as dream on has been
defensively for that team a five-year
deal that could come you know in the
radius of 200 million dollars every
night I think it's a no-brainer that
Kevin Durant's the guy you invest in I'm
shocked that they suspend a dream on
green for a game but there any more
details aside from what he was saying to
Durant or what he called him that would
warrant a one game suspension a public
humiliation you know I've asked around
and the the sense that I get is the
language and the tone of it wasn't there
was a confrontation in the locker room
you know you've probably talked about
this but a couple of years ago when he
and Steve Kerr went at it in the locker
room in that if that doesn't warrant a
suspension kind of going after your
coach never to be separated physically I
mean I don't know what is but I think it
was the language and the tone that he
used you know I I know that draymond is
a fiery guy but I do put a lot of this
on draymond Green because you know look
he made a mistake in that moment of the
game I mean it was a clear mistake he
should have handed the ball to Durant in
that moment instead he you know it
almost reminded me that seemed Fresh
Prince where you know Carlton throws the
ball at the rim no not passed the ball
to Will Smith at the end of a game but
he should have he should have given the
ball to Durant in that moment and if he
if he had just walked
away from that and kind of tapped his
chest said my bad it would defuse the
whole thing instead he got really
defensive now that in and of itself
didn't warrant a suspension but the
language he used for what I was told is
what brought to that level okay but if
you're Kevin Durant if draymond Green
has a problem with Kevin Durant that you
know what you're making this season all
about you and free agency next year why
would you want to continue to play with
draymond Green if he acts this way so I
I don't understand he recruited Kevin
Durant but what he's saying and how he
actually Kevin Durant that that's not
going to lead Kevin Durant to going you
know what on second thought maybe I'll
take less and stay with Golden State
yeah I mean that's that's true I don't
know the Kevin Durant is thinking that
far ahead right now
I think Kevin Durant is looking at this
season and how we can best win and
draymond Green is how we can best win
and look these two if you go back this
YouTube clips everywhere they have had
some you know very visible on court
spats about where a guy is supposed to
be and you know offense defense stuff so
this is this is an elevated version of
what they've gone through but it's not
the first time they've they've kind of
gone through all this stuff so I think
they'll be able to put it past them and
ultimately then I'm not sure that
draymond Green and Katie's feelings
about him is going to be the most
influential thing or even a influential
thing in his decision this summer I
think there's gonna be a lot of
variables for him including some off the
court things he probably wants to get
into yeah but I get the feeling that
he's gone from Golden State the quad you
to I look I wrote this therapist today
and you know there are you know you when
you you talk about big free agents over
the last five or six years whether it's
LeBron at different points or others
there's always some ambiguity bunk
amongst NBA types like well I don't know
I mean he could stay in Cleveland it
could go to stay in Miami you know other
guys they could go here there there are
more people that speak with absolute
certainty about Kevin Durant leaving
Golden State than I've ever seen before
I mean guys that I talk to you regularly
that that know kind of like to speculate
about this stuff and some of it is
informed speculation but they say with
absolute certainty no chance that Kevin
Durant comes back there so it's it's
surprising that that's the attitude
across the league
we're talking to Chris Mannix Sports
Illustrated senior Bass
ball writer and then the question could
you see him playing with LeBron James I
know Steve Andy Smith said he thinks
it's the Knicks or the Lakers I think
it's the Knicks but would Kevin Durant
help LeBron's legacy I I don't know if
there's competition on who's the better
player I don't know if Katie's wired
that way but do you want to go to the
Lakers and maybe you help LeBron get one
or two more titles and then all of a
sudden you've changed his status maybe
in people's minds ya know you're a
hundred percent right and to tweak it a
little bit I don't know that that Kevin
Durant Minds you know LeBron winning
championships I think he wants to be the
guy that wins more and you know you the
biggest reason I was told for by
different people that that Kevin won't
wind up in Los Angeles with the Lakers
is because of that because he wants to
be you know if assuming he gets that
third championship this year he wants to
be the Kobe of this era the Michael
Jordan of this era the magic of this era
he wants to be the guy that has the most
championships and you can't do that if
you're going down there and sharing
championships with LeBron they're out
the other part of it is you know I think
there's a keen awareness amongst NBA
players of what it means to win in New
York I mean you win in New York it's
like winning three championships
somewhere else I mean ever won anything
since the early 1970s you become a star
on a different level if you can lead
that Knicks team to a championship and I
don't know how big a fact this would be
for Durant but you'd be doing something
that LeBron James refused to do I mean
in 2010 LeBron passed on chance to go to
the Knicks and rebuild them into a
championship contender Kevin Durant
could go to Knicks and do what he didn't
Jimmy Butler made his debut last night
76ers losing to Orlando but if I gave
you the 76ers or the field in the East
who you taking that's easy I'm taking
the field okay I don't his bond even
still better in Toronto yeah Toronto
yeah Boston Toronto maybe Milwaukee I
think are still better at this point it
doesn't throwing guys together in
assuming they'll work it never really
made me sense to me there's too many
examples of the times that that didn't
work
the Sixers to me still have massive
shooting problems that they're you
it's a good move to have JJ reddick as a
starter now out there on the floor with
Jimmy Butler you know if for no other
reason maybe a less pressure-filled
situation can do something to
rehabilitate Markel folds into a usable
piece with that team but yeah how they
get enough floor spacing end of game
situations then can you keep Ben Simmons
on the floor if Jimmy Butler's the guy
Jimmy bother also hasn't played up-tempo
in in a number of years Ben Simmons
plays up-tempo all the time this there's
a lot of question marks about this team
where there there aren't as many
question marks about Toronto Boston once
they eventually get it together and even
Milwaukee which is a really good team
right now is Carmelo done now he's not
done it there are going to be teams that
that are willing to give him to sign I
think they're you know if he gets waived
and it may be a situation where he gets
waived with the understanding that team
X is going to pick him up there's gonna
be a team out there you know Miami
wanted him pretty badly this offseason
Portland's been trying to get him for
like three years so I don't think that
interest has waned significantly so well
it's one of those two teams or somebody
else
somebody's gonna be willing to take a
flyer on Carmelo what is happening in
Houston though because this is you know
I I think it's become habit-forming here
first you go wow it's just a coincidence
they're not playing well and and now all
of a sudden we're looking at them and
saying is is this who the Rockets are
well a couple of things are contributing
to this I mean you can throw injuries in
but every kind of as injuries and harden
being out for for a stretch is certainly
a factor you know they made you know
what is what I thought at the time and
looks like now a big mistake not
bringing the band back together
you know letting Trevor Ariza walk I
know we got a big one year deal that
would have had pretty significant luxury
tax implications but Trevor Ariza and
additional what he did on the floor was
a great glue guy in the locker room Luke
Mabon moot a to a lesser degree was a
huge part of that defense I know they
got James Ennis and he's a good player
but you know brought it a why it didn't
make absolute sense to bring everybody
back no matter the cost of a team that
was up 3-2 in the Conference Finals the
other thing that doesn't get talked
about enough
was was the retirement and now unretire
Monteux Jeff is Dilek who you know was
the guy that Mike D'Antoni leaned on to
run the defense every single night now
in different stops Mike's had different
guys in New York it was Mike Woodson in
in in Houston it's Jeff as Dilek so him
walking away that late in in the off
season I think had a big effect on what
they do defensively they could still
rally at this point but you know their
roster is is not not as good as at what
it was the end of last year I know that
you were in Los Angeles had a chance to
take inference he's a stand-up act at
the Comedy Store would you make it yeah
well okay Fritzie was an NBA team his
performance was an NBA team oh that's a
good question um Sacramento like it was
it was it it had some talent but it was
dysfunctional at times if that makes
sense okay it I would say this Dan I
it would have been funnier if I didn't
know Fritzi like I'm sitting there and I
now I now have way too much information
about what happens in his bedroom I mean
there's there was just a lot of up
inside of Mesa the point where I don't
think and I don't know this will ever
happen but I don't think I can ever be
in the same room with fritzy and his
wife because I just can't David there
was there was some sports metaphors that
were all over the place I can't I can't
do it okay but the Sacramento Kings do
have potential young and promising
I agree look he wasn't there was some I
mean I look be honest and of comic has
got to be tough there was some bad
stand-up comics that night so I think
he's got potential his jokes were were
solid I just sort of was a little
uncomfortable with with the the the
subject matter if you will it kind of
made me squirm a little bit alright
that's a fair assessment and I
appreciate that it's always fought for
it see you have a response from Chris
Mannix I think that was very fair and
well said I'll take a you know
up-and-coming Sacramento Kings and you
know a lot of people would be
uncomfortable with
some blue humor and inflammatory bowel
disease right off the bat and you know I
understand why you may not want to hang
out with me and the wife of the future
dinner gathering that would be extremely
uncomfortable Thank You Todd I mean
there were flags coming out of places I
don't know what was going on I think the
spouse yeah yeah thank you Chris hi dad
that's a Chris Mannix Sports Illustrated
senior writer for more Dan Patrick show
to the audience channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]